written in distinctive elegant script
the Dutchess of Sussex in her own words
addressed in a private letter to her
estranged father now a very public and
painful description of their rift daddy
the letter starts it's with a heavy
heart that I write this not
understanding why you've chosen to take
this path turning a blind eye to the
pain you're causing the fall five pages
were sent more than six months ago after
her wedding to Prince Harry Thomas
Markel was unable to walk his daughter
down the aisle because he'd had two
heart attacks she tells him she was
horrified to only find out through a
tabloid and criticizes his decisions to
give interviews to journalists if you
love me she says as you tell the press
you do please stop please allow us to
live our lives in peace please stop
lying please stop creating so much pain
please stop exploiting my relationship
with my husband you can be incredibly
hurtful in letters now frizzle had an
on-off relationship with her father for
a decade they reunited she says she has
empathy for Megan who's pregnant but
they're having her own child may make a
difference having a baby made a huge
difference because I'm now a parent and
I'm as fallible and flawed as any parent
ever has been I'll give me more I then
had a partner who became a father and so
I saw the father look like up close
being a father can be really hard in a
different way
being a mother is incredibly hard but
now that I am a parent I can talk to him
on a level that I didn't have before
Megan's father claims he only made his
daughter's letter public after her
friends misrepresented its contents in
interviews it's not known whether the
Duchess had originally asked them to
speak out but he's reported to have said
her letter was not loving nor reaching
out as claimed Megan is getting a much
harder time the most partly because her
family are collaborating with some of
the media her half-sister to a degree
her father to a degree the other
relations are really talking form
it seems and that is really very
distressing so officer Kensington Palace
are going to be very upset for her that
just also describes how Thomas markle's
broken her heart into a million pieces
saying to hear about the attacks you've
made at Harry in the press who was
nothing but patient kind and
understanding with you is perhaps the
most painful of all
while mr. markl insists he wants to
reunite with Megan
the reality is far from what the Royals
would want this father-daughter
relationship is now more than ever a
public open wound Adelle Robinson Sky
News